my god yes that married people know more
about than Kylie Jenner am i right
do you know that she has a makeup line I
didn't know that because everyone knows
we're living under [ __ ] Wow
how long do you think it takes meeting
you right in the morning zero fifty
minutes 50 minutes that's generous takes
me an hour and a half usually why you're
married to what we call a natural beauty
we're like she just wakes up and that's
what she looks like people like me I
know what I'm not listen I'm fine Josie
Josie you are naturally beautiful thank
you you think are real on makeup you can
say yes it's not an insult like [ __ ] I
hope you can tell them where your makeup
do you how much I spent on this I can
definitely tell when you're ready makeup
because it's like it's a span and that's
all that's what Kylie is all about
making statements so I have a little
surprise for you you know you're my very
own with that I am going to give her a
Kylie Jenner makeup yeah I thought yours
is gonna give her like a single girl
makeover no we're doing Kylie Jenner
makeup here is just some of my favorite
products
excellent this is my daily routine
makeup bag okay so this is my makeup
your makeup bag is about the size of my
daily lip gloss this has everything I
need in that area let me about your
beauty routine oh gosh foundation you do
okay under-eye concealer because [ __ ]
won't work the entire I get like you're
wearing mascara but no I just
you're one lips a lipstick I have this
too so we're gonna give you what I think
is Kylie Jenner makeover again I'm not a
makeup artist I just really love makeup
Ted and I are actually going out after
this so Oh God so you're gonna look
awesome
first I'm going to do your eyes I'm
gonna do a blend of some like bronzes
and some dark reds now do you have any
insecurities when it comes to makeup or
like beauty products I go light because
if I went heavy I'm worried that people
would be like you know you did that one
right Oh interesting
half the time none of us know what we're
doing most of the time it's happy
accidents it's like Bob Ross paintings
then I'm going to contour your face
because is this just like totally
foreign to you okay clearly I do not
know what you're doing right now and
then I'm going to spread some fun
station over you then I'm going to blend
it all in with a beauty blender and a
brush if I blend it up we're gonna blend
you up sorry then I'm going to go back
in and contour your eyes a little bit
Kylie cream shadow
I'm gonna use the tie line then I'm
going to do your eyebrows yes I've been
looking forward to this okay I did good
I'm going to highlight with Becca
stamping pop what's it made of like oh
yes oh and I'm gonna give you lashes
Brown have you ever worn around what I
don't think it's you're coming I think
we go cool Kylie Stewart I think we do
this is cork a quirky cork a look court
k like her sister Courtney Courtney oh
it was like quirky like freaky not
exactly good to go here all right okay
now come and sit right to your new life
I don't think I've ever seen arrow with
dart whoops you're like what do I need
to quit just like and the lips are
totally working it's a look that is so
bold it takes so much confidence to pull
that off that you just I look at you I'm
Myka ho
this woman knows what she's about and
she is just fake therapy it's a vampire
look for a reason yeah look I do look
like myself but I also hate it you look
great I gotta be honest you look like a
[ __ ] schmuck [ __ ] yeah I got smoked
yeah okay would bang my job here is a
good job like if I'm gonna work oh it's
makeup forever
thanks for watching see you next time on
married very single